I'm Nathan I'm the lead product manager
for developers on tango and daydream and
today I get to talk to you about
something that is super awesome at least
I think it is and then is immersive
computing immersive computing is a
family of very related technologies that
we believe is going to revolutionize how
people interact with information and
experience the world with VR we can
actually take the we actually take
people from the world that they live in
sq there we go
we can actually take people from the
world they live in into unfamiliar new
worlds we can make them feel physically
present in new places both real and
imaginary with excuse me with AR we can
actually bring the world of information
into our own we can enhance with
information interactivity the actual
objects and environments we find
ourselves in and that's both of these
together are incredibly powerful ways of
enhancing and expanding the way that we
interact with the world and of course at
Google we think this is amazing because
our mission is about interactivity and
about information right we think about
our mission statement organizing the
world's information making it
universally accessible and useful and
that's why when we think about you know
VR and AR and immersive computing we
know that VR is going to make our
ability to interview surrounded by it's
access information incredibly more
immersive an AR is going to make the
information that we're surrounded by
sensors from our phones and from the
Internet of Things from the data sources
that we have about our our products and
our users and the physical objects that
surround us and make all of that
dramatically more useful and interactive
at Google we also think a lot I think
about scale like all of you do right we
want to maximize our reach and our
impact and we believe that fundamentally
scale and immersive computing is going
to come from mobile computing form
factors so already today right there's
no surprise there's many is billions
more smart phones in the world than in
PCs people have spoken and they say the
future is mobile and so what you'll see
is everything that we're doing around
immersive computing will be built around
mobile form factors so
I'm going to talk to you about two
platforms two products specifically the
first of which is daydream our platform
for mobile virtual reality and tango
from mobile augmented reality and I
think this is a great time actually to
be doing immersive computing work
because it's a Miss finally becoming
real just a few weeks ago we launched
the pixel which is the first day G ready
phone in the world the first one that
embodies our vision for what's possible
in VR on your phone and just a couple
days ago Lenovo allowed announced that
it released the fab 2 Pro which is the
very first tango ready phone in the
world so this technology is not
theoretical it's not abstract like you
can go to a Best Buy
or the Google store and get these
devices now and actually experience for
yourself virtual reality and augmented
reality available on your phone so we'll
dive into both of these platforms a
little more detail so you can understand
the specifics and the opportunities with
daydream we're talking about virtual
reality and the challenge with VR is
you're creating a sense of presence for
the user that requires you to be really
to have hardware and software that work
perfectly with one another you know when
somebody takes their phone and puts it
interviewer and straps it on their head
you're teleporting them somewhere else
you're creating a synthetic sense of
reality and when it's flawless
its transformative and when it's not
it's often not that awesome and so we've
been working very carefully to design
the hardware the pixel phone and the
sari in the viewer and all the software
like Android n to work well to be
perfect for VR and you know for months
and months my team has been like
obsessing over the details of these
platforms making sure that the phones
are actually ready to deliver amazing VR
experiences that our viewer is
lightweight and comfortable that it has
a controller that you can interact with
but for us we think it's honestly not
good enough to build something that's
great we want as many people in the
world to experience VR as possible and
so we've done the really hard work to
actually make the viewer and controller
available for a very affordable price
point and also they're sold together so
as a developer you can know exactly what
input every single day dream user is
going to have
when they launch your app we know that
fragmentation is a big concern for a lot
of developers they were making sure that
that's not a problem on daydream also of
course like I said this is of really
matters when it's real when you go to a
store and buy it and take it home and
experience it for yourself and daydream
view is actually going to be available
in stores in just a few days a week from
today on November the 10th which is also
super super exciting so the foundation
of daydream is of course the phone right
all the compute all the sensors are in
the phone that you they use for the
device but daydream is not about a
specific phone like the pixel or only
phones made by Google like I said we
believe in scale and scale is going to
mean the way that Android does it which
is through partnerships and other OEMs
and so it's actually a standard called
daydream ready and the daydream ready
certification is something that we
actually worked directly with OEMs to
make sure that every phone that's tagged
a dream ready is actually going to be
great for VR that means things like
certifying that there's low persistence
displays high compute SOC s and accurate
low latency sensors on the device this
way as a developer you know that every
day Jim ready phone will run your app
really well and for consumers they know
that when they buy a daydream ready
phone the entire catalog is going to
work great on also every day Jim ready
phone is running Android n which is our
first version of Android actually
optimized to be great at VR we've done
some really fundamental innovations
we've done things like sustained
performance mode so we actually managed
this the SOC inside the phone we
basically have different power
management in VR to balance performance
and runtime we've got very sophisticated
head tracking that fuses all the sensors
on the device to figure out where you're
looking in space very very accurately at
very low latency but of course it's
still your phone right and sometimes you
get notifications you get phone calls
and so we've done course to take a core
Android system UI and made it VR aware
so if you get a call while you're in VR
you can actually stay in VR and decide
for yourself whether you want to answer
that call or not so the phone is great
but without with just a phone it's not
VR it's a phone and to be transformative
we need a viewer that lets you see the
world in 3d and a controller that lets
you inter
act with it and that's what daydream
view is all about on the viewer it's
actually very simple
it's electronically inert which means
that all if the smarts are in the phone
itself and the job of the viewer is to
be as comfortable as humanly possible
we've actually tried to take a lot of
cues from apparel from soft goods if you
look at a lot of kind of high-tech VR
they're inspired more by gadgets by you
know DVD players and consoles but nobody
wears you know electronics on your body
nobody wants to put a DVD player on
their face so we try to think about like
for a thing that you wear let's design
it in the same way to be made of fabric
soft and approachable the controller
looks actually pretty simple but it's
honestly really expressive and there's a
challenge in VR which is when you have a
controller you need to be able use it
blindfolded right you're wearing a
viewer and so you need a controller
that's both accessible for users that
they can operate without looking at
their hands but expressive for
developers and so we have a few
different surfaces the key is a
clickable touchpad it's an analogue
touchpad that supports touch and click
separately there's an app button that's
up to you to do whatever you want within
a home button that we reserved for key
actions like taking the user from your
app back to daydream home most
critically though this is a motion
controller it has a nine axis IMU that
can give you very very accurate 3d
orientation and you can use that the way
you would like a wiimote on a console
actually if you will a live sense of
hand presence you can map virtual
objects to what the real controller is
doing and people will feel a very
powerful connection of how the virtual
world is connected to their physical
actions so all that is enough to you
know get you from the real world into VR
right but for us the platform is about
it actually it has to extend pass to
that entry point and we know that for
most of you you want to actually not
just make great software you want to
make a living right you have businesses
to run and so for us we've been very
focused on both discovery and
monetization the screen behind me here
is what's called daydream home this is
the first place that every user goes
when they put their viewer into the
headset and step into VR the top three
big tiles there
discovery windows their services where
we curate and expose the best original
content for daydream we know that early
adopters of V are going to be extremely
hungry for new content and we want to
surface that as often and as prominently
as possible the cool thing is that we
actually can leverage deep linking in
these discovery windows not just to
promote new apps but new experiences
within existing apps so if you're
building a platform a service you have
new content coming in all the time we
can actually surface that new content
not just the launch of the feature of
the platform itself
so that's discovery it helps get people
exposed to the best what we have to
offer but monetization is really
important as well so we've brought
actually with the launch of daydream the
Play Store into VR so users can browse
for content check out collections buy
apps and install them all without
leaving VR it's an incredibly easy
low-friction way for people to find new
content of course that's awesome but we
know that many of you have the whole
businesses built on selling you know
goods on transacting within applications
not selling premium goods upfront and so
we're actually launching with in-app
purchases are not billing day and date
with the launch of daydream so whether
you're a freemium developer or a premium
developer or somewhere in between you
can bring your content and your business
model into VR right out of the gate and
for me this is all super exciting but
nothing really speaks to the power of
the platform or the what developers are
already creating for it so I think we'll
check out a video that shows exactly
that
[Music]
all right well that gives you a sense of
what daydream is all about and now I'm
going to switch gears and I'm going to
talk about tango which is our a our
technology and platform and where
daydreams sort of core technological
challenge and opportunity for innovation
is about creating a sense of presence
taking people from the real world and
helping them teleport to somewhere else
tango is all about basically taking the
computers that we have in our pocket and
teaching them to see the world the same
way that we do and if you think about
you know our phones we have them with us
everywhere and they have some amazing
sensors in them right they have
accelerometers and gyros and GPS and
cameras but they still don't
fundamentally think of the world or see
it and understand it to the same level
that humans do for example if you take a
look at this coffee table here it's not
just a bunch of pixels as humans we look
at it and we know that there's important
features that there are edges that are
sharp and corners that we might bump
into we know that some sides are flat
that it has a top and a bottom we know
that that object doesn't just exist in
isolation we know that there are other
objects around it that that Vaes is on
top of the coffee table that the coffee
table is on you know near the sofa and
in fact we know not just about objects
in their relationship we know we think
about spaces we think about how this
coffee table is in a room and that room
has many things in it and as you start
to think about and understand a space
you can actually consider not just the
physical objects but what might also be
there you can imagine that if this
family had a baby they might add some
additional objects in fact it's not just
about what might be there it's about how
the objects behave that there are things
like doorknobs and light switches that
are interactive that have special
meaning and special functionality in the
context of that space and tango is all
about enabling phones to understand the
world exactly like we do in the
structure in a structured in deep
fashion and there's really three
technologies that allow us to do that
the first is motion tracking there's
depth perception and aerial learning and
these are kind of the pillars that tango
is built on top of so with motion
tracking it's all about how
bring the phone understand where it is
in space both its position and
orientation as you move around and you
know I think well I have GPS doesn't
that already give me position I've got a
gyro and accelerometer doesn't that give
me orientation well they do but they're
very course right GPS is accurate to
centimeters or meters and worse when
you're indoors the gyros have drift over
time but tango fuses all of that and use
the technology called visual and
inertial odometry to get very very
precise estimates of exactly where it is
in space
and you can see example kind of the 360
3d movement all the time super precise
super low latency but we also want to
understand the world that device
interacts and not just where it is in
space but what the outside world looks
like that's where we get to depth
perception depth perception allows us to
actually understand the 3d nature of the
world we can tell you that some objects
are closed and some objects are far we
can tell you that the walls are flat and
vertical and floors are flat and
horizontal and some things are not flat
at all and when you combine depth
perception with motion tracking you can
actually build a very detailed accurate
map of the world the sort of the phone
sense of where it is in space and where
spaces around it but when you
unfortunately like with just those two
things you get to build a map and then
you leave the app and we've lost it so
that's where aerial learning comes in
where aerial learning allows us to not
just build up a map of the world but to
remember it over time not just remember
the world but to share maps across users
so if somebody's mapped an area and been
there before other users can benefit
from that information and when you
combine motion tracking and depth
perception and aerial learning you can
get some incredibly powerful experiences
you know you can actually build a very
precise measuring tape using your phone
and a touchscreen you never have to
carry a measuring tape again just like
phones have already replaced flashlights
for most people if you're a commerce app
you can actually have people you know
look at it good and see how it's going
to look in their real space size scale
and lighting before they've ever made
the purchase and hear and hear more
about that later this afternoon of
course for gaming augmented reality is
awesome you can have virtual pets
inhabit the same world you do or gaming
that actually interacts with the
physical objects and dynamically
responds to the real-world environment
you find yourself in and last you can
explore your world more fully there's
everything from like highly precise
indoor navigation to enhance learning to
actually augmenting the objects around
us with additional information and
interactivity and free these are
incredibly exciting opportunities and I
hope that together I've given you an
opportunity opera and idea of the
opportunity and immersive computing in
both VR through daydream and AR for
tango and although these things may
sound like very exotic and crazy the
foundations are actually incredibly
familiar to you as developers both
daydream and tango are built on top of
Android and Android is of course the
foundation for both of them we have
native C++ and DK's and Java SDKs for
both day dreamin tango so actually
enhancing your existing apps with either
AR or VR is going to be super
straightforward if you're a native
Android developer today and of course
with Android you get Google Play and
like you saw we've integrated everything
from the stores to IEP deeply into both
tango and daydream so you can leverage
all of the transactions and payments and
dozens of countries all of the user
analytics and customer engagement
features all that familiar and powerful
tool set is available for you today in
AR and VR we know that many of you if
you're doing 3d already or maybe using a
game engine like unity or unreal and
we've built deep partnerships with both
epic the maker of unreal and with unity
2 for first-class native support for
both tango and daydream and that means
that if you're using these game engines
you'll get first-class super easy to use
very high performance AR and VR with
both of these world-class game engines
you know I hope all this is giving you a
chance a sense of the potential the
vision the scale and the impact that
immersive computing is going to have if
you want to know more if you want to be
a developer for daydream or tango or
hopefully both check them out online or
developer resources and tons more
information are available for you we
can't wait to see what you make thank
you so much for your time
you